alejandro quiere resolver el siguiente
problema una partícula se mueve en línea
recta con una velocidad de dt igual a
menos de al cuadrado más 8 metros por
segundo donde t es el tiempo en segundos
en t igualados la distancia de la
partícula al lugar de origen es de 5
metros cuál es la distancia total
recorrida por la partícula entre t
igualados y t igual a 6 segundos qué
expresión debe usar alejandro para
resolver el problema no tenemos que
encontrar la respuesta sino simplemente
elegir la expresión apropiada pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolver esto por
su cuenta
resolvamos estos juntos la pregunta
clave aquí es encontrar la distancia
total que recorre la partícula entre t
igualados y t igual a 6 segundos sólo
nos interesa lo que ocurre entre estos
dos momentos del tiempo no nos interesa
que la distancia de la partícula al
punto inicial sea de 5 metros en t
igualados esta información no la
necesitamos lo primero en lo que podemos
pensar es en que quizá la distancia sea
la integral de la función velocidad ya
lo hemos visto varias veces así que
encontrar el cambio en una cantidad
tomamos el tiempo inicial y el tiempo
final para después integrar la función
velocidad es así de sencillo debemos ser
cuidadosos si la pregunta fuera cuál es
el desplazamiento de la partícula entre
t igualados y t igual a 6 esta sería la
respuesta correcta con esto encontramos
el desplazamiento entre t igualados y te
igual a 6 pero no nos están preguntando
al desplazamiento nos preguntan la
distancia total recorrida por la
partícula una forma de pensar en esto es
que integramos la función rapidez en
lugar de la función velocidad ya vimos
que si integramos la función velocidad
obtendremos el desplazamiento cuál es la
función rapidez es la magnitud de la
función velocidad en una dimensión es el
valor absoluto de la función velocidad
si integramos esto que es la rapidez
obtendremos la distancia entre t
igualados y t igual a 6 y esto coincide
con la tercera opción la cuarta opción
es una distracción interesante pero no
es la respuesta correcta la segunda
opción de prima de 6
a la aceleración si tomamos la derivada
de la función velocidad y la evaluamos a
los seis segundos tendremos la
aceleración de la partícula en ese
momento esta opción no nos interesa la
primera opción nos da el valor absoluto
de la diferencia de velocidades entre el
tiempo 6 y el tiempo 2 que tampoco nos
interesa y con esto terminamos